so I was just thinking about the Roman
Empire as one
does there's that whole meme uh
where all guys are thinking about the
Roman Empire at least once a day and
half the population is confused whether
it's true or not but more seriously
thinking about the wars going on in the
world today and as you know uh war and
military conquest has been a big part of
uh Roman society and culture and it I
think has been a big part of most
Empires and dynasties throughout human
history so yeah they usually uh came as
a result of Conquest I mean there's some
like the orer Hungarian Empire where
there was just a lot of sort of clever
marriages um but fundamentally there's
an engine of conquest and they celebrate
excellence in Warfare many of the
leaders were excellent generals yeah
that kind of thing so big picture
question grock approved I ask this is a
good question to ask contested grock
approved uh at least on fun mode
uh uh to what degree do you think war is
part of human nature versus a
consequence of uh how human societies
are structured I asked this
as you have somehow controversially been
a proponent of peace I'm I'm generally a
proponent of peace I mean ignorance is
perhaps in my view the Real Enemy to be
countered that's the real hard part not
you know fighting other
humans um but all All Creatures fight I
mean the the jungle is a you look at the
people think of of this nature as
perhaps some sort of peaceful thing but
in fact it is not there's some quite
funny w w hog thing where he's like in
the jungle like saying that it's like
basically just murder and death in every
direction m i mean the plants and
animals in the jungle are constantly
trying to killing each other every
single day every minute so it's not like
uh you know we're unusual in that
respect well this there's a relevant
question here whether with greater
intelligence uh comes greater control
over these base instincts for
violence yes we have much more V ability
to control our our um limpic Instinct
for violence than say a chimpanzee and
in fact if you looks at say chimpanze
Society it is not friendly I mean the
bovos are an exception um but chimpanze
Society
is uh filled with violence and it's
quite quite horrific frankly that that's
that's how Olympic system in action like
you don't want to be on the wrong side
of a chimpanzee he'll eat your face off
and tear your nuts off yeah basically
there's no limits or ethics or uh the
Romans said just War there's no just war
in the chimpanzees societies is is war
and and dominance by any means necessary
yeah chimpan Society is a Like A
Primitive version of human society um
it's they're not like peac loving
basically um at all um there there's
extreme violence um and then once in a
while some some somebody who's watched
too many Disney movies decides to raise
a chimpanzee as a pet um and then that
eats their face or if they're not so or
Che their fingers off that kind of thing
yeah it's happened several times uh
ripping your nuts off is an interesting
strategy
for interaction some it's happened to
people it's un unfortunate like that's I
guess a one way to ensure that the other
chimp doesn't like you know contribute
to the Jane pool well from a martial
arts perspective it's a fascinating
strategy the not
rer I wonder which of the martial arts
teaches that I think it's safe to say if
somebody's got your nuts in their ass
and as the option rubing them wolf you
will be amenable to uh whatever they
yeah to
say